[Music]
in i on earth our planet
in peril cbs news will bring you a full
week of coverage to mark the 51st
annual 51st rather annual celebration of
earth day
next thursday correspondents all around
the globe will look at how climate
change is affecting earth and examine
creative efforts
to heal the planet here is a look at
just some of that coverage
[Music]
i'm mark phillips out here in the
english channel
a lot of history's been made here ice
ages invasions
but none of that compares to what
climate change is doing to these waters
to the oceans of the world and to us
this is dundora about 30 acres of
plastic waste the country's choking in
but i'll tell you about one young woman
who's turned this mountain of despair
into one of hope
i'm tony decouple in new york harbor
where researchers are learning how
toxins on land and even what we flush
can end up here
in our nation's waterways life in new
york harbor we'll show you what's being
done to clean up
this precious resource
these five wind turbines provide almost
all of the offshore wind power
in the united states but that's about to
change big time
it is cool to see it up close i'm ben
tracy off the coast of rhode island and
we'll show you plans to install
enough of these to provide power for
more than 10 million homes
[Music]
how are these little guys part of the
plan to tackle
discrimination climate change and
inspire
the next generation of black farmers
that's a lot
i'm michelle miller in sloanesville new
york
that story coming up on cbs
this morning
and all that special coverage and more i
on earth our planet in peril kicks off
monday here
on cbs this morning and cbs news will
bring you a series of reports on climate
and environmental stories
across every broadcast and platform all
next week
leading up to earth day you are very
busy you're in the water yeah this is
somebody who just took the red eye in
from california
but i noticed that mark phillips mark
phillips got to go sailing you got to go
wait now new york new york harbor not as
picturesque
but important i'm back on the air today
bravo you i'm choking